the largest number of people ever is
expected to hit the road for Memorial
Day weekend yep it is here triple-a
estimates nearly 43 million Americans
will travel 88% of them by car CTM
national correspondent tarika Duncan is
in Jersey City New Jersey
so Jericka here's a question which the
drivers watch out for this holiday
weekend well right now it I'd say it
would be the rain and of course that
typical holiday weekend congestion is
nothing new but the 37 million drivers
that are expected to hit the road this
weekend can see an increase at the pump
on average nationwide the gas prices
have jumped nearly $3 a gallon prices
across the country have increased by an
average of about 47 cents in the last
three months however those of you taking
road trips will see some relief and
rental car and hotel costs car rental
prices have declined by seven percent
compared with last year and mid-range
hotel prices have dipped about two to
three percent now triple-a highly
recommends getting those maintenance
checks maintenance checks rather before
hitting the road while it sounds like
common sense there's a good reason for
the reminder more than 350,000 people
are expected to experience some type of
car trouble that includes flat tires
dead batteries and being locked out of
your vehicle which really means you just
need to slow down but all in all the big
congestion will start this evening and a
lot of the big cities you can expect
delays of up to three hours longer than
your normal commute glad I take the
subway drink it thank you sure it's nice
to get away sure it's hard to get there
there's nothing scarier that when that
engine light goes on in the middle of a
vacation trips yeah
or you can do what we do we'll just work
this week no traffic there